welcome back to dc thursday after
a great summer i hope everyone
enjoyed your time
uh this summer and as i know i did
we're really excited to have
an amazing guest today to to kick off
our fall sessions
and we have oscar gauche otherwise known
as bg
who is a partner and cto at 8 bc which
is a venture capital firm
in silicon valley
bg focuses on investing in early
startups
including b2b and sas companies as well
as enterprise infrastructure
and data-driven businesses so he's a
great fit for the program
um we've had a great relationship over
time
originally met at data council
which is quite exciting so bg has been a
member of our community
for the last couple years or so um
before that to finish the introduction
um bg was an engineering executive
for multiple different companies
including linkedin where he was the
founding head of data infrastructure
team
and previously before that bg ran
engineering at wright media which was
acquired by yahoo
and he also worked at oracle and
informix so bg there's a lot of
data stuff there of course i can't
forget
your position at cto of nerdwallet as
well which is a very fast-growing
company
where you presided over a lot of scale
and a lot of growth there as well
so bg in addition to all that you have a
phd from yale um in cs what more can i
say did i miss something
um tell me please
i think you covered it really well
anyway pete thanks so much for inviting
me i've been a big fan of data council
and you and your leadership
and how you built a network it's pretty
amazing so thank you for inviting me
no i i mean you you you covered it you
know i did a phd in
graph algorithms many years ago and just
accidentally went to a company i didn't
know was a very hot company called
informix it was the
hottest database company of the time and
i didn't have much of a database
background but you know absolutely loved
working in databases and i would say
informix and oracle kind of shaped my
engineering culture always got to work
with people smarter than me and on very
beautifully architected products you
know where systems design was important
i would say systems design and the
powers of abstraction that information
oracle had in their products has
influenced me
not just in you know building tech but
also in building teams and works and
even now when i look at companies and
entrepreneurs and products as an
investor um
so very so very early it's a very early
start um in the database world
yeah in formics and
um i want to hear a little bit more
about the the background your background
as well um i just want to remind the
audience that we will take questions in
the chat so if folks have questions for
you about your experience your career
or other questions that cross their mind
they can feel free to sign
to sound off in the chat and we'll try
to get to the questions to the extent
that we can
yeah i would love to take questions live
and people can always follow up with me
happy to be of service to anybody
attending the talk so
yeah but go ahead yeah so so so after
informix um you know tell us a little
bit more about where you went from there
you know um in from informix i was lucky
to implement something called optimizer
directors which is a fairly hard thing
in you know query optimization for
databases and that was one reason that
oracle hired me
i and i ended up spending many years at
oracle and you know our groups there
were phenomenal all all these companies
came out of the two floors from the
rdbms kernel side you know snowflake
came out rubric came out nutanix came
out so just a bunch of
really smart
great cultured people again just repeat
myself a lot of my engineering culture
came from came from watching and
learning at oracle i went to yahoo a bit
late i got really lucky i was recruited
to inside yahoo after a fairly short
time to run this hot company that we had
just bought
called call right media
and while ads has its pros and cons
about human society i would say for a
computer scientist and software engineer
you know ads is an amazing area to work
in because it sits at the confluence of
databases distributed systems economic
systems marketplace design and ai very
heavy use of ai right media was amazing
for multiple reasons you know amazing
business pioneering
part around ad exchanges but also i was
lucky to have a team around me
many of whom later followed me to
linkedin and you know that way yahoo was
just a very formative part of my career
and i would say right media the culture
was amazing
and i just want to call out i think
yahoo
probably doesn't get as much love and
respect now in this generation of
engineers but i'm going to tell you
yahoo engineering especially early yahoo
was just world-class you know
at the level of google and also it was a
highly entrepreneurial culture
internally you know moved very fast very
start-up oriented so just want to give a
shout out to
the mentorship and learning that i went
through at yahoo
i was very lucky uh now in hindsight to
you know few of us went to
linkedin you know my boss david hinke
and then he hired us jeff weiner was
very serious about investing in data a
few of us were hired
just an anecdote is
i
this i have not put on my resume you
know
my good friend gk was supposed to run
security at linkedin
couldn't join on the same day as me jk
used to be head of security at yahoo and
i had to run and build the security team
at linkedin
so i was head of security and head of
data and neither of them quite quite
existed so linkedin i obviously was a
very you know pivotal informative part
of my career and the network and what we
got to do so we'll dive into it a bit
more
um after linkedin i want to run kind of
a smaller b2c company so made a very
contrarian bet to run technology at
nerdwallet amazing ceo tim chen justin
um and it was fun being there because
you know it was more
you know going into a company in a zero
to one phase where you're trying to turn
it into a tech focus and product focus
company is always hard but a great
learning experience and then you know i
actually was going to go spend some time
with hillary clinton this administration
to work on privacy that didn't happen
became a fairly prolific seed investor
uh joe lonsdale was the founder of
valentine's hvc and i became friends and
you know when things led to one another
and then as a lark i i joined hvc so
that was in full time back as a partner
in 2017 and you know i'm just starting
my fifth year now so yeah got it got it
well that's um yeah that's that that's
quite the background i i wanted to ask
you actually um
like what what was the thought behind
getting the phd in cs did you think you
were going to go into academia was that
the plan or how did you sort of get
dragged into industry and how did that
happen
um i think my career is always a set of
coincidences and with complete lack of
planning so if i give people advice
about their figures feel free to know i
i loved i loved algorithms i would say
computers i mean you know um
you know going to college in india we
didn't have access to as much computing
power or you know personal computers as
people did in the us so you know we
studied computer science as a science
really hard so our backgrounds for that
generation of computer scientists was
fairly deep
and yeah kind of multi-dimensional and
computer science was a smaller topic
that was a smaller discipline than but i
would say i was just in love with the
study of algorithms so you know i
uh i had no i didn't know what i was
going to do um going to academia was one
plan it turned out my advisor said hey
you will thrive in silicon valley go go
work on software that's basically what
happened and i interviewed and i got
offers from hp labs and from informix
and just chose informix accidentally so
a set of wonderful coincidences uh but
still still remain uh
uh you know student and lover of
computer science in general
got it and you mentioned a couple times
i think um already
the the culture at some of those early
companies that you worked at um informix
um yahoo right media
just as as examples
oracle
um what was what was great about those
cultures and
um what's missing if anything from sort
of current engineering culture that is
sort of a
a contrast to you
um
yahoo culture was more entrepreneurial
you know build your own infrastructure
but if you look at companies like
database companies at that time and
during when i graduated from a phd in 95
there were not a lot of places to go to
do you know deep systems work or deep
computer science you know you went to
bed labs you did work on networking you
went to sun or you went to sgi to build
machines and compilers
or you went to database companies like
you know ingress
tandem
db to ibm oracle inform is very small
and very hard to get into very select i
would say just
the fact that this was
the the
the luckiest thing that happened if i
look back is
databases is one area where industry has
innovated on par with academia
and so you are going into an industry
where absolutely cutting edge uh
problems are being solved in terms of
systems design in terms of how to
support applications i mean think about
it
with airline reservation systems all the
way to uh you know bank atms running on
or you know running on oracle databases
we take it for granted now it was not
true then you know things were happening
so i would say new industries were being
created because databases were being
innovated on by these small set of
companies including oracle so that's one
one is so they were kind of pioneering
companies second is the quality of
hiring
promotions leadership in these companies
was extremely high and consistent you
had to be really good to kind of gain
influence in the company i mean look at
the founders of snowflake you know i was
lucky to work with them very closely for
many years on the oracle parallel query
engine they're amazing world-class
engineers look at the you know one of
the founders of yoga bike that we're an
investor in condom one of the star
engineers out of oracle right so i would
say just the quality of hiring was great
the other part is
the products were architected
beautifully with lots of attention to
separation of concerns and
architecture was great apis were great
when you start your career working on
beautifully architected products you
kind of get to know what does good
software look like so those were some of
the reasons that you know i feel very
obligated and happy you know looking
back at my base at informatics
that's great well i have to say that
from running data council over the years
um you know we've primarily been an
industry conference but
when we get academic speakers especially
in the databases category to come and
share
cutting edge research
to me those are some of the most
interesting talks that we've had at data
council over the years
because i think that just fundamentally
any engineer of any type
you know really appreciates um sort of
the architecture of how data is
processed because data is used in other
systems whether they're a quote data
engineer or not
um data is so important and
you know most of us remember like the
how our eyes lit up when we first
learned sql for instance and the power
of the of the relational join and i
think that
these these basic notions are magic um
for engineers of all shapes and sizes
not just data engineers and um to hear
that the academic research um that's
sort of shaping and and and moving um
you know data theory um and systems
forward has been it's been amazing so i
totally understand that it is you're
absolutely right just a brief point
there i think
the academic
side is so productive also because the
industry side is eager to accept and
imbibe
and incorporate stuff so you know
problems are jointly defined and often
problems are um
you know decomposable into parts some of
which is solvable inside of academia
without having access to huge amounts of
data and systems right i would say
database is one of the few industries
disputed systems and databases but this
sort of joint innovation has happened
and it's still continuing and you see
that kind of an ai infrastructure now
you see that in many many other levels
you know everything around data systems
i'd say yeah
yep great
well let's um let's jump let's jump to
the linkedin um portion of your
experience because so much happened
there and some so many of us
no you know we're on a first name basis
with the open source that came out of
linkedin right
um we use kafka we know about pinot um
we've heard about espresso
um you know we know about data hub and
and metadata systems increasingly um in
this present era um you know all of
these things were birthed at linkedin in
the last 10 or so years um
tell us like when you joined linkedin
what was the state of the data
infrastructure then
as best as you can recall
um
there wasn't like a very heavily
demarcated data infrastructure team i
think there are five or six engineers i
would say
too
much of linkedin used to run on oracle
when i joined and you know jean-luc who
was the founding cto of
linkedin very very smart guy
he had helped implement a very important
system called data bus
which you know is a change capture
data pipeline uh uh coming out of the
back end of oracle logs very hard system
but if you go look back he gave a
beautiful talk about it way back 2007
you know we came in early 2010
i think the main you know infrastructure
if you want to build infrastructure
inside a company the first thing that
has to happen is kind of
organizational buy-in and cultural
buy-in right so when we got a few of us
from yahoo got to uh
linkedin and when i was you know under a
lot of support from my boss david hinke
and our ceo jeff wiener you know amazing
champions of the infrastructure team
when i was you know trying to build out
the team and hire these all these
amazing engineers who i'll name shortly
i think the
what the way
linkedin had reached success at that
time is by running as a set of product
organizations so there was like very
creative product managers who had their
own engineering counterparts and
linkedin at that time hadn't reached the
level of scale where you need to buy you
know build like globally scalable web
skill system it didn't right smaller
when i got there we were probably in the
70 million range or something you know
which was large but not that large i
mean when i left yahoo
yahoo the number of unique users in our
database in my team was 880 million i
still i still remember the number
december of 2009 right so you're done
and then limping graph was growing
densifying and just growing in leaps and
bounds so the model that you can run
things with product and engineering paid
up works up to a certain point that way
every product engineering lead tries to
build her own infrastructure and it
works up to a certain point then it's
stoppable right because it's not cost
efficient and many people who are well
versed in product engineering are not
well versed in building distributed
systems and databases so i think it took
a lot of guts from management to decide
that hey we gotta create these
horizontal disciplines not just in you
know ops not just in security but in
data also so i think a lot of that
demarcation happened it all looks very
well structured now but that's not how
it was you know every time you change
culture
decision making prioritization where
will resources go it is it is sausage
making right change is hard right so
that's one but i would say
reed jeff
henke they were all amazingly supportive
but especially because jeff and henke
had that muscle memory coming in from
yahoo right they had seen horizontal
teams work both in yahoo search as well
as in yahoo ads fair enough so i would
say that was one important thing and at
that time when we went in jay had just
started thinking about kafka
data bus was the kind of the
change capture pipeline everything was
running on oracle uh and you know
initially
it was hard i mean i was very lucky to
have all these amazingly talented
builders engineers leaders joined you
know sri shanka
uh who is now founder of akril couple
who now you know runs much of linkedin
data swaroop who's founder of actual
uh kishore came in a little bit later
you know founder of pino chavdar who
built database who came all of them came
in from you know my you know past
network at
uh yahoo and oracle and
initially we focused on solving the
database problem you know we tried out
[ __ ] it didn't work and you know it
took how many how many different
databases would you say like how many
different types of data stores would you
have in those days
at that time on the online side remember
linkedin yahoo you broadly defined data
infrastructure and systems into three
different uh
uh pieces one is online which is you
know the site back end where you're
doing oltp essentially at scale
that's you know then you have your data
warehouse analytics what we got data
lake today that let's call that offline
then the third data systems that you
have is what is called near line which
are all the ai indexes you know all the
graph indexes which are
which are mostly read-only but you build
like specialized serving systems there
right ads back and so on so online
offline nearly initially i was just
working on the online site right it was
mostly working on oracle but with a
bunch of redis caches on top that's it
you know and things were falling over
all the time because you're talking
about yahoo are you talking about
linkedin i'm talking about linkedin
sorry
so broadly to look at data
infrastructure you can look at this what
i call the three-phase ecosystem right
you have online which is the side-facing
stuff
source of truth systems offline which is
all your analytics data
data warehouse stuff and you know you
have to focus and then then you have
newer land which are your ai indexes
graph indexes which we kept up to date
but mostly heavy read only so we focused
on the online side
and you know i remember we went to uh
either sigmon or vldbe conference in
arizona and i mustered up courage and
approached you know the god jeffrey dean
from google and said hey you know we are
trying to build a new back end that
linkedin you know you know and you know
be we have to move quickly and you know
yet make sure that it works and you know
building source of truth systems old
systems are hard i still remember he was
very kind gave me one piece of advice
which i still remember sri shankar
he said try to use
as much battle tested open source as
possible
you know don't don't don't try to
re-implement it
so i would say because
uh at that time you know we were looking
at supporting linkedin profile linkedin
feeds linkedin mailbox a few use cases
which were kind of not scaling
you know we decided that the data model
had to be mongo-ish so kind of document
style so the apis and the programming
model being exposed to the programmers
is not sql it is actually like mongo-ish
so no no sql-ish news equation but we
decided that
the entire back-end should be like
battle tested open source we we picked
my sequel and because my sequel allowed
like a bunch of pluggable back ends like
you know db and isam we picked my signal
with with you know db but you know large
part of the beauty initially was in
thinking through the application
programming model i still remember i
would say
um sri shankar kapil swarup these guys
really thought that through i still
remember being in like white boarding
sessions because ultimately the product
organizations were all looking at us
newbies saying hey man what are you
going to build for us and you know we
can't like rewrite our entire
application so
the orm layer the programming layer was
really important and then what happened
a series of innovations happened in
espresso um kapil and kishore came up
with like a open source project later
called helix which is based on zookeeper
for shard management right so we have to
think about how to manage clusters
and
these guys and we were lucky to attract
amazing engineers which is a recurring
theme if you want to do something like
distributed systems and data it took
many years for oracle to be for um i
forgive me espresso to be stabilized but
you know now
i was talking to couple last night um at
linkedin
like hundreds of use cases almost
everything other than the graph runs on
espresso today so
so tell us
because the audience may or may not have
um knowledge um deeply as to what
espresso is um
so
give us a quick overview of the
architecture and sort of what it's for
it's a source of truth distributed
document style database you know sharded
uh massively scalable
you know with a sql with the sql backend
and kind of a document style programming
front end that's amazing
and you you chose to build this instead
of using [ __ ] why
at that time this was 2010 early 2010.
[ __ ] did not scale [ __ ] now and mango
then are quite different you know
remember [ __ ] i forget the name of the
company they bought i should look it up
they had a serious issue
right
tangent
then they bought like this database
company which whose back end they used
to solve a lot of issues around
partition locks and row locks yeah they
basically they had some reader writer
issues so in our experiments it did not
scale up the kind of throughput and
scale that we needed it to so looking
back unit was a high very high risk to
build espresso so
that was an online site by that time you
know jay
amazingly creative leader and builder
jake krabs you know had come up with the
idea of kafka which was initially for
shipping logs right so it didn't didn't
have to be like exact ones and we had
two pipelines running one for change
data through data bus which we also open
source by the way all of these projects
people can find beautiful papers written
about especially database they all have
great papers written you can just go go
look it up and later on we merged
databus and kafka you know towards the
end of my junior which was the right
design decision where the shipping
mechanism all became kafka but and so on
the online side there were all these
creative projects uh and and what
happened about midway through my time at
linkedin to just go back is initially i
was you know lucky to run the online
side which included all these pieces and
then we expanded and kind of centralized
uh
leadership for all of data so then i
for for like two and a half years also
had to
uh be
be responsible for the entire offline
systems the data warehouse the hdf you
know the entire hadoop system etl
pipelines bi everything
on that side very briefly
uh you know we had a lot of stuff
running like oracle was running the
warehouse we had greenplum we had
um i forget what else we had um
force company forgetting the name um um
you know i had to make some hard
decisions around getting all of them out
and you know we centralized around
hadoop for the entire etl and the ai
index building part
and we centralized on teradata for the
for the warehouse and i was talking to
couple last night as of now
you know teradata has been moved out the
entire thing is now on like massive
extra bytes of data on hadoop as kind of
the blob store with like spark and
presto running on top and you know they
now have all the bi stuff running on
pino so
just like
linkedin itself the reason the point i'm
trying to make is
the
huge success of the business and the
business being data driven has enabled
linkedin
to go through three to four generations
of data infrastructure he writes now you
know
that's
looking back i would say that's an
uncommon theme i would say
google
did everything before us i would say
yahoo did a bunch of things that were
never published but yahoo did it
facebook and linkedin did it very well
um
not a lot of companies have done it at
that at that level of innovation where
you know the entire data stack they've
almost built so that's one arc of the
story the other arc of the story is
and i cannot take any credit there i
would say i learned a lot about open
source from my from my yahoo days you
know yahoo had tremendous culture around
open open hackathons and taking stuff to
production from hackathons and citizen
programmers coming in
so a lot of the culture of yahoo was
amazingly open and democratic
based on open and free software and you
know linkedin
for the leaders who came in before me
there was already a propensity towards
open source
i was lucky with my team you know that
we were lucky to kind of uh s kind of
accelerated this openness turned out to
be a great way to involve community
turned out to be a great hiring
mechanism and i would say that is
something we should all be very
collectively proud of that so much of
software at linkedin was actually open
sourced
um that you know to be fair now so many
startups use stuff that came out of say
facebook linkedin
and i would say as a computer scientist
as a programmer as a software engineer i
feel really proud that this sort of
network effect was created by this small
group of companies and you know if you
look at it after that twitter netflix
pinterest airbnb have kind of carried on
the mantle so i would say that's like a
huge cultural part of silicon valley
that i was lucky to be there and a bunch
of us we still believe very strongly on
the open source site and it continues to
this day
in my
how did linkedin decide which open
source projects like generally speaking
to open source which projects open
source and which not to was there any
kind of
um rubric there or how did that work
practice speaking i you know i don't
know how it is today during my time it
was
you know it had to be something fairly
heavyweight like
you whether you were doing uh a bunch of
the apm stuff or deployment stuff on top
of hadoop you know azkaban gamer
linkedin also i think something called
white elephant a bunch of stuff and then
under couples but you know leadership i
mean the on the offline side a lot of
heavy duty i think the common theme is
the following
any project that has to be open source
should have solved a really important
use case pro you know really important
problem inside the company and should be
running in production like there has to
be some weight that it's a non-trivial
it's a non-trivial project it has hit
production and it is going to make
linkedin proud of the company proud to
see it open sourced and it will it will
be useful so i would say the bar during
our time and i think even now is quite
high
that it essentially has to be deep
enough solve a business use
case and has to have been stabilized in
production and wasn't seen as a as a
hiring benefit um
largely
very much because
uh that was a very strong way of
reaching universities and junior junior
programmers and at linkedin and later on
i mean at
at all companies i would say a lot of
kind of young
new college grad programmers get
attracted to companies because of the
beauty quality and the culture of
software that comes from open source so
i would say it's a very strong secondary
network effect and talent interaction
for sure definitely
well um
i guess there's kind of two aspects
there that would be fun to to
you know get a follow-up from you on one
is
just the notion of building a horizontal
data platform organization um
because it seemed like according to your
cultural
sort of timeline like that was what had
to happen first linkedin had to buy in
to building a horizontal
um sort of you know parts of the team
and that enabled all of this these great
things out of beta infrastructure to
emerge secondly on top of that you also
made a commitment to open source and to
open source your own stuff
because it was so groundbreaking and um
was had the potential to you know change
industry and also sort of bring top
engineers to linkedin
how do you think this maps these two
strategies map to
i i i don't know how to describe it a
mere mortal company today like should
everyone aspire to be
a linkedin and have a horizontal data a
data organization and you know hiring
the best engineers um you know in the
world to write open source like is that
is that something that every company can
do or what's your learning from that in
terms of how that sort of informs
um you know the the way a team or a
culture or an organization should think
about structuring their their data team
and systems now in the present day
yeah um i would say it depends and i'm
going to give you a partly provocative
answer so bear with me for a second i
would say the world today versus the
world in 2009 10 when we started all
this stuff is quite different
i would say the contributions from
facebook linkedin google about you know
verticalized data specialized data
systems right not just in data movement
like kafka and pulsar and you know nat
and others not just in you know graph
engines not just in document cell
databases not just in shortable postgres
databases
all of that has now a lot of that has
been open source and is available as
services from public cloud providers
right so from
purely distributed systems and database
point of view
it is a lot of stuff is already
available so a lot of
so companies
just don't need to build that
just they can just use services
available on public clouds to do it and
a lot of these services are based on
open source projects so you can actually
go read the code and kind of there's
this information
so the depends part of it is
i think we were all fortunate at silicon
valley to be at the right place at the
right time where all of these companies
were in hyper growth whether it's google
or yahoo or linkedin or facebook or
netflix
and data was a core part of the feedback
loop and data was a core part of the
business model so
it took didn't take long for the
management to understand for the funders
inside the company to understand that
this is a this is not a cost it's
actually a high positive roi effort that
if you build the data infrastructure and
the ai infrastructure and analytics
infrastructure well and systems
infrastructure it will pay off in rows
because we are scaling
now so that means any company trying to
build its own data infrastructure for
example in any way
the business model has to be there
the budget has to be there the roi has
to be there
that's one the other part is just
remember building these teams is
incredibly difficult if you think of
engineering as a funnel and kind of
application programmers and designers
sitting on top and distributed systems
and database people sitting in the
bottom the numbers are exponentially
less the number of trained people you
get who can go build systems like this
because you cannot learn systems only by
taking classes right systems is also an
art so i would say
if a company is going to have is
reaching a scale
and has data as a critical business
reason then they can afford to go build
infrastructure on their own
otherwise this level of infrastructure
is kind of hard to build so i would say
we will notice this more as an exception
as a rule now i will what's that's kind
of the provocative part of the statement
the other part is if you look at
infrastructure coming in from the
application tier whether it's in ai
whether it's in bi whether it's in
orchestration whether you're doing micro
service orchestration or you're doing
etl orchestration
those are important but smaller projects
what i'm noticing is
application companies sas companies at
scale are actually investing in that
often they're taking an open source
project and contributing to it and
expanding it so i expect that that kind
of contributions to
infrastructure and open source is going
to keep on growing from a specialized
setup companies but building the kind of
very heavy machinery that we had to
build from these five companies are
named is going to remain an exception
and not a rule
yep got it well um it's amazing to you
know many of the folks that you've named
already in our discussion obviously have
left linkedin to start
best of breed companies around these
open source
projects and making them available
um to the rest of the ecosystem so
it's quite extraordinary the data
culture that this
um this philosophy birthed and
as we've said already um you know
thankfully there's
many folks there that that want to
continue to push forward these projects
and commercialize them in ways that are
even more usable than just raw open
source bits um you know for the rest of
the community and and the rest of
industry
indeed indeed uh yeah it's uh exciting
the one thing i'd like to repeat is
um
you know open source now that you know
i'm an investor and we have a bunch of
open source companies you know we have
gigabyte which is open source postgres
we have actual which is open source data
hub we have uh a new investment in the
area of you know panda that is also open
source we have tetrad which is in the
open source service mesh area open
source has become important for one more
reason when large companies want to buy
software from startups
they want to risk remediate you know say
that hey i'm going to buy infrastructure
this is going to stay with me for 10
years i want to make sure it's open so
it's not just for quality but for access
that that's a it's a downside management
play we hadn't thought of that back 10
years ago it turns out in the economic
life cycle of software the buying
selling of software open source is also
an extremely important thing for risk
remediation and transparency so that's
just just want to make a point there
yeah yeah great point um that that's uh
that's a more mature understanding of
sort of you know where the open source
world has tracked and and some of the
unseen value that it brings as well at
least unseen from back in the day as you
mentioned
um well let's let's switch gears a
little bit and talk um
a bit more
about the broader
ecosystem
and sort of market insights you might
have i'm curious like what are the main
patterns
or or what if you prefer what mental
model do you use
um when sort of looking at this space
overall
put your investor hat on right i mean i
think this is a sort of an investor kind
um
so i'm curious to your thoughts there
yes um
too many i think you know data and data
below ai
and data below automation if you think
of ai directed workflows and automation
directed workflows and application
directory workflows on top
data is going to remain the first class
citizen and there's going to be
tremendous innovation around data going
forward so it's a very exciting european
few areas that we at vc think is really
important is
uh going bottom up we think you know the
convergence of the graduation of apm
products to observability products kind
of you know traces logs multi-level
tracing
how do you build these back ends i would
say what will be the new back end of a
of a data dog or new relic or splunk is
elastic going to work i would say
the very hard problem you know time
series databases with high cardinality
high dimensions so i would say from a
database perspective
uh that's an exciting area and i was
talking to kishore a couple of months
ago
you know runs the company around pino
and one of his
interesting observations was that a lot
of the back ends you know that pino
druid and others and your click house
are built in the context of near
real-time olap the kind of the
multi-tiered storage you know how you do
indexing how do you do learned indexes
that there is an opportunity for
convergence of that between the offline
airline side and the online side of
observability so very fertile area hard
things to build
and you have to be very clever and go to
market so that's one area second is we
expect because so much verticalized data
services are available from every one
every one of the three cloud service
vendor cloud vendors
fragmentation will remain uh
our reality data personas are going to
grow there are going to be more personas
who will do things with data use data
store data make decisions around data so
it is pointless uh you know more
departments will use data and more
innovative ways for top line reasons not
bottom line so we expect it's going to
be exponential growth in usage of data
and there will be fragmentation and one
of the themes that we have bet on and
you know we started work on this during
my time at linkedin became an amazing
project called data hub is
is we feel like the metadata tier is
going to gain more and more importance
and you you know building data catalogs
privacy workflows governance workflows
search and discovery workflows on top of
uh extensible material model and tier is
going to be a very important layer and
you know we have also bet on actual for
that but i think metadata is going to be
key so number one was
that observability apm and olap back
ends is going to be really important
uh uh metadata is going to be really
important the other part is a less sexy
but you know hvc is very big on thinking
horizontal but going to market vertical
we have found that as legacy high time
industries like insurance healthcare
finance e-commerce
uh even you know supply chain and
logistics as they are going through
digital transformation which is cloud
first automation first data first i
don't like to mention ai because i think
uh we in silicon valley probably hype ai
more than we should but that's again a
provocative point but a cloud first data
first enterprise what we are finding is
there is enough bespoke um difficulty
and opportunity in data models and data
sources for these verticals so you know
how do you build a data lake for one of
these verticals really really easily
i've heard multiple times from very
senior people at two of the major cloud
vendors that if they had easily
buildable data lakes for these verticals
that would be really important so again
is it pure infrastructure no but it's
application specific platforms that
you're building uh so
um
otherwise you know everything
so in that respect in that respect um
is that to say then that you feel like
the majority of the innovation
will sort of be coming from
the applica application specific
implementations of data infrastructure
in the vertical but really that's to say
that
the the actual data storage patterns
that we have enough data storage
patterns already and
um i guess i'm curious if if you think
that's true or if you think there's
missing data storage and access patterns
at the core
storage layer that haven't been covered
by systems like pino and some of the
other more forward-looking
database systems like is there anything
missing there or is all the innovation
just going to be on the applications now
and sort of weaponizing this for for
vertical specific use cases i think the
applications will drive requirements so
the question is do you build
infrastructure to support only those
applications or is your infrastructure
horizontal enough so it's kind of a
goldilocks problem you know it's kind of
hard to define if you look at the api
economy that we are going through
who knew that after your leave plaid and
a strike would become
serious application specific
infrastructures which are giving rise to
enormous amount of business processes
and innovation so
you know is it purely horizontal no but
it's horizontal enough for that vertical
so that was the spirit behind my
observation that it's very hard to
separate out vertical and horizontal
very clearly you know there's a grey
area and it's all defined by application
needs and damp that said i see that next
generation graph engines next
i already mentioned back ends of
observability right next generation time
series databases next generation
metadata engines
these are all going to remain important
are they from an investor point of view
are each of them going to give rise to
10 billion dollar snowflakes i'm not
sure about it are they going to remain
important problems for innovation will
happen yes
fair enough
the i think we only mentioned the data
stuff but i think the other important
thing around data is we what we at hvc
think about you know applications
anywhere thesis ultimately the other
important point i want to make is
the application revolution is
accelerating you know it's not just in
the java spring boot community but it's
now in the you know the jam stack
community with netlify and versailles
where you're building headless
applications more easily it is the
emergence of graphql as kind of the data
data broker integration layer
and what we are finding now is that on
all these legacy companies the speed of
application development which is cloud
native data native is going extremely
fast the data tier has to keep pace with
it and that means a cloud data tier
which is you know available anywhere
replicated anywhere at the at the push
of a button so we expect that cloud
native databases which are due
geo-replicated geo-distributed
lets you implement security privacy
governance rules easily
the push that is coming from the
edge edge applications applications
anywhere is also going to lead to
innovations in data tier these were just
three or four of my favorite areas but i
can go through ten more but for lack of
time i think i'm just very good at pause
at this time yeah yeah that's that's uh
that's very helpful and interesting um i
just want to remind the audience if
anyone has any questions to feel free to
chime in in the chat and uh we'll take
your questions for bg before we wrap up
um
bg i also wanted to ask you you know we
sort of
and and you've thrown around this term
in our chat right data first
enterprise um
can we drill into that a little bit more
like what what do you see that as really
meaning um you know what what sort of
values are our spouse besides well i
mean
tell us in your own words because i'm
here i'm curious to hear how you might
frame it
yeah you know we had an old saying back
in our yahoo days i'm sure it's borrowed
from somewhere is you know what can be
measured can be fixed right
and you know we also had everybody use
the term garbage and garbage outright so
i think
uh data first is actually uh the first
and foremost pointer on data first is a
cultural transformation that
every business process every uh
department whether it's hr whether it's
sales whether it's marketing not just
you know data driven products in the eye
that people are measuring stuff that
they're metrics based so i would say
that revolution in in
both enterprise software development is
usage and also enterprise business
models is happening
and what that means is people are
becoming
more data driven in their in their
decision making what that leads to is an
explosion of personas you know you have
data personas user personas business
analyst personas
who are reflecting in every enterprise
department whether it's specific to an
insurance department or specific you
know it's more general like hr
recruiting
as i said sales marketing supply chain
so i would say that the what
this
this doesn't just happen randomly i
think data first is both growth of data
data democracy but it has to be careful
uh attention paid to the processes
around usage of data generation of data
and also articulation of business value
of data that's kind of those are some of
the proof points around how growth of
personas how growth of data-driven
decisions is kind of
fit into what i'm alluded into as a data
data first enterprise ultimately it's
about measurement based decision making
that everything is based on metrics and
more metrics well managed to give rise
to transparency and they create secular
feedback loops inside the company which
lead to more better data-driven
decisions
and is this yeah
it does is this explosion of
presumably companies desiring to become
data-driven and desiring to track more
metrics and
um you know
more analytics across different lines of
business is this what you
believe produces the the data explosion
that drives the interest in valuations
of infrastructure companies right now or
is there something else
that's required
you just nailed it i would say the
growth of business critical applications
in enterprises and the growth of
user and you know budgetary personas and
enterprises around data are the two
secular forces the cross product of
these two applications cross personas is
what is going to drive data
data innovation and i think it's a
non-linear thing we're going to see more
and more innovation and data there
um yeah
i'll just leave it at that that just
that part is mind-boggling what we see
now in all the verticals i mentioned
healthcare pharma
e-commerce
insurance all the all the regulated
stuff financial services it's just
mind-boggling as enterprises are trying
to become software first they're also
trying to become cloud first and data
first it's a very important phase and we
expect
much more innovation to come our way not
less
agreed
um well i want to ask you as we wrap up
um
what advice would you give for
engineers out there who are looking to
future-proof their career
in data um like how do you escape to
where the puck is going so to speak
in this fast moving space and
what are the core skills and
experiences and sort of awarenesses
you you would advise engineers out there
to do to stay relevant and to continue
to increase their their impact as this
data infrastructure or world moves
forward
yeah i think uh i mean i think growing
as an engineer requires kind of
conscious set of optimizations um
what is possible today that was not
possible in our generation as engineers
is you can even be a full stack engineer
that was not possible back in the day
right because you have services today
you can use database you can spin up
stuff easily you don't have to worry
about compute clusters you have all
these amazing front-end frameworks not
just you know not this node.js you can
use so i would say
uh one part of generic being a good
generic engineer is to be able to do
full stack work part of the time right
because you just learned the entire
layering three four two years as well
but i think what's important as you go
through your career in the first five
ten years is kind of having some
conscious uh choices around
understanding what tier do you want to
work in do you want to work in the
ops tier absolutely bare bones in the
cloud management side do you want to
work in the database tier do you want to
work in the ai in front here do you want
to work in the business logic product
what i call product engineering here
which is where you're riding the body of
micro services right or do you want to
build scaffolding and infrastructure
around you want to go and actually build
a system for kubernetes or do you want
to be a front-end
programmer who uses our frameworks and
is very good at working with designers i
think a little bit of conscious
understanding of
the fact that all of these tiers have
different kind of crafts
and different kind of design decisions
different flavor of day-to-day work
different flavor in which personas you
work with i think a bit of conscious
thinking around that is important so
that's one overall it's good to learn
the basics of uh you know data
services databases it's good to learn
the basics of ai at least in using stuff
that's
out there and i would say it's good to
know the full stack stuff as kind of
general knowledge but ultimately you
know if you're a good software engineer
and you're good around data you're good
around cloud you're good around ai
what an amazing time to be an engineer i
mean this is the hottest commodity
as you see what is the most common thing
we have here from portfolio companies at
every phase can you help me hire 10 more
engineers so
i would say
the technical aid to coming back to the
answer to your question the technical
area what tier you enjoy working is
important the other part is look i mean
you have to enjoy your network
you have to enjoy the kind of engineers
you work with
with and communicate with that is really
important i mean that being part of a
guild you know being part of a
craftsperson's network to me is
extremely important kind of talking shop
there and you know open source allows
you to do that but there are many forums
today that it was not there before many
more you know you know reddits and
subreddits that was not there when we
were growing up i would say
those are some of the tips but
ultimately
who to all the software engineers out
there man are you lucky to be a good
software engineer this is the best time
to you know to be an engineer so yeah it
is a golden era as you said i you sort
of surprised me i didn't think you were
going to go straight for full stack when
i was asking really about you know data
specialization but i think
um it's a it's an interesting point
right and
um it's a it's a golden era to be an
engineer especially when you can sort of
build a product from front to back
as an entrepreneur or as a side project
or as a hustle or whatever
and you can just sort of experiment and
explore
many different layers of the engineering
process
with a lot of that stuff teed up for you
and
meaningful services that you can use in
a weekend and um and then sort of from
there
of course to determine where you might
want to focus and go in deeper
i i want to repeat something slightly
contrary and unpopular i think
i think full stack is a good thing to
learn and do for a short while
but
the the conflict is always between being
a jack of all trades versus going deep
into an area so i think
everybody who's an engineer should kind
of think about that on on you know on on
her own and kind of decide what tier you
want to work in yep so great
well bc um it's been really great to
chat with you um i know that you're
quite active
on linkedin the platform being an
ex-linkedin employee so i know folks can
find you there
um
so i'll encourage them to to reach out
to you and and to connect with you there
yeah i know you're all you're always
looking for interesting startups to
invest in across these axes that we've
discussed
um and you know you're you're very
supportive um in the companies that
we've co-invested in um it's been
amazing to see you dive in um with the
other founders and and really support
them early on as is sort of our our
motto and value around here as well so
it's been it's been great so i
appreciate yeah
trevor thanks pete it's been such a
pleasure working with you these last
couple of years i would say people can
reach me at
buscar abc.com anytime or you can
linkedin and you know we are interested
from hvc we are interested in anything
b2b sas anything anything horizontal
anything around cloud and data and you
know we are not just here to invest
people happy to be helpful i'm also part
of the engineering community i don't
think of myself only as a vc but also as
a supporter so if you're looking for
support if you want to chat always
available and what a great community
you're building pete thanks for data
council
yeah any time um it's been a pleasure
and thanks for joining us again
thank you
so to our to our audience um thanks for
joining us um make sure to stay tuned
for additional episodes of dc thursday
as we announce them and if you want to
be notified directly from youtube don't
forget to subscribe and hit the bell
icon so that you get notifications when
we go online again in the future
remember you can find all the old
episodes of dc thursday on youtube
that you can view in a time-shifted way
at your leisure so thanks for joining us
everyone we'll see